natalia guaino et marina baranova sont
mères et filles l'ukrainienne natalia a
vécu à kiev jusqu'à ses 30 ans elle
habite désormais dans les yvelines la
guerre en ukraine quasiment inconcevable
pour elle j'arrive toujours pas à y
croire en fait ben on les lit tension ça
dure déjà depuis des années mais c'est
vrai que la guerre comme ça avec des
bombes qui tombent sur des villes s'est
fait incroyable franchement je n'étais
pas prête même sentiment pour sa fille
marina parti à l'âge de 6 ans de kiev il
lui reste encore de la famille là-bas
qui est ressemble je suis pas fier d'un
mot qui a fait fort pour pour décrire ça
mais moi j'ai mon père qui l'a pas en
fait qui est à kiev et du coup j'ai un
peu le les infos en temps réel qui sont
encore plus horrible en fait que ce
qu'on entend ce qu'on voit à la télé
donc ouais mais c'est ça en fait à la
sirène qui a retenti nylon il reçoit un
sms pour 10 euros cachez-vous et ils
doivent s'abriter le plus près possible
on dans des sous sols les parkings
fameuse endroit isolé où ils risquent
moins leur vie on habitait là bas il ya
quelques années donc en soi on aurait pu
être lapin en fait je n'ai pas déménager
en montrait dans les bonbons
concrètement très loin physiquement du
conflit les deux femmes soutiennent à
leur manière leur famille et amis
marina est parti plusieurs fois
manifesté plus j'y suis allé le jeudi
qu'il y avait une manifestation je suis
allé le samedi le dimanche
ben c'est de faire tout ce que je peux
après c'est pas énorme mais en fait
d'ici on sent vraiment impuissant par
manifester je partage beaucoup sur eux
sur les réseaux que ce qui se passe de
ce qui est des gens qui sont très
étranges être un agent quand des liens
de deux soutiens mes amis aussi qu'ils
veulent aider
les deux militaires par exemple les deux
juges y est nous sommes là d'alarmé ou
pourraient l'être pro craignant ne veut
pas dire être contre la population russe
ici sur le territoire évinois il n'y a
pas de conflit entre les deux peuples
qui j'ai plusieurs amis qui sont
d'origine russe et y est pareil qu ils
m'ont envoyé plein de messages en disant
qu' elles comprennent pas on comprend
pas comment c'est possible il supporte
le crem il sait c'est très important
nous ne peuple était toujours très très
proche donc là que la culture chrétienne
et la culture russes télé deux cultures
qui sont communes dans les yvelines
l'association russe aux fans du chéné
prône justement les liens des deux pays
et même plus largement de la communauté
russophone sans émettre david sur les
questions géopolitiques
nous avons semble que la risée
l'association dans son positionnement
politique parce que c'est la meilleure
capacité de préserver l'avenir on est
que centré sur les dimensions
culturelles alors avec des activités
mais on fait des événements on fait
parfois des concerts si vous voulez des
spectacles de danse avec des troupes qui
viennent de certaines régions
russophones après les périodes de crise
il ya toujours des périodes de
reconstruction et c'est la culture qu'il
faut préserver qui vous permettra de
reconstruire l'association laïque est
prête à se mobiliser en cas de demande
l'aide d'un de leurs 300 adhérents des
plates formes de soutien ont été mises
en place sur internet